- What's that?
- That's another check in
and check out of somebody
who had the perfect day so we
put it on the wall of fame.
You gonna be the next one?
- [Mathew Voiceover] Because
we do check in and check out,
students feel supported through
a positive relationship every single day,
which builds their capacity
to be successful students.
- I know you can do it, okay.
- [Mathew Voiceover] At the
Fall-Hamilton, we've really put
a lot of effort in building
positive relationships.
- Hi
- [Emily] How was your day?
- [Student] Good
- One strategy we utilize
is our check in and check out system,
where adults are meeting
with kids every single day
and it's not their classroom teacher.
We have 41 students on
check in and check out here.
You're gonna do great are you?
We identify the students that just need
a little bit more support where
they're struggling meeting
some of their requirements
on a educational level,
but more of a social and
emotional level as well.
- [Teacher] You did, I'm so proud of you.
- The child knows every day
they come in this building
that somebody's excited
to see them in the morning
and excited to see them
right before they leave.
- [Emily] Hey Moriah
- Hi
- You ready to have
another great day today?
- Yup
- My check in check out buddy,
her name is Moriah and
she's in fourth grade.
She has three goals
everyday that she works on.
What are your goals for today?
- Listen, be on task and nice.
- Awesome
She can get zero, one, or two
points for each of her goals.
- The goal sheet is based
off the student's needs
and it is agreed upon by
the classroom teacher and the student.
So whatever they're struggling with
is what the goal is set around.
Then every increment of the day,
at the end of a literacy block,
at the of a mathematics
block, at the end of recess,
they're just getting feedback.
- How about being nice?
Do you think you're a
nice to everyone around?
- Yes
- Good job, I agree you
were doing a great job.
- Whoever the teacher is will give
her points throughout the day.
If she had a bad day, I
try to just let her know
that she still has a capability
to do great tomorrow.
But today was a really great day.
You had a perfect day.
She got a perfect score
on her goals for the day.
- What I let about check in and check out
that you get prizes and you
get to see what you did good
and what you did wrong and
you can do better next time.
- We try to pick things that
the kids like, school supplies,
or non-tangible things like
a positive phone call home
to the parent congratulating them.
It is a great day for Moriah isn't it?
So it's not just about the points.
The relationship and the accountability
is really the important part.
- How was your day?
- Good.
Actually it was fantastic.
- Fantastic?
- Mr.Portell, he's our
principal and my mentor.
You go to him and them
he asks about your day
and if you had a problem somewhere,
we'll talk about that and
see how you can fix it.
- We've seen kids transform
their own opinions of themselves.
Paydon, man he had a rough year last year.
Just to see his growth
on a foundation level,
being able to be in a class
all day without incident
and being able to start
growing on his academics.
So do you think you
knocked it out of the park?
That's what I'm talking about.
That's been a huge success.
- You did it with me.
- That's right, no but
you did it on your own.
That's you my man, nice work.